well don't get your tinsel in a tangle
there's a local holiday pop-up bar
that's back with a whole new look yes
it's time to slay all day until january
1st at mary crimson inside red rock and
rocky got a preview
it is the most wonderful time of the
year back here at red rock mary crimson
is back the holiday pop-up bar that we
all love and met for the first time last
year right joe yes we did and it was
when you walked in it was that kind of
quintessential holiday feel you had a
lot of reds and greens but this year
seems very chic and elegant yep merry
crimson is back and this year it's
tinsel town yep it's kind of our elegant
take on christmas over here at red rock
casino okay so what is your the head of
guest experience here at red rock so
what what is the guest experience when
you walk in kind of take me on a tour
yeah well it starts from the outside as
soon as you come in your first photo
moment is our tunnel and then we come up
to our living room vignette that really
pays tribute to the holidays i love it
and that's what everyone wants right the
instagram photo everything and even down
to our cocktails which taylor will show
you later everything is instagramable in
here perfect so what can you actually do
here
so you can come in and have a great time
right
reservations are definitely recommended
but not needed entry is complementary um
you can reach out to our through our
website and books and tables so we have
everything from igloos to fire pits
outside and then you come and sign
tables and even our live elf on the
shelf is back live up on the shelf what
does that mean what is the live elf on
the show it's deimos our elf the redrock
elf he'll be running around delivering
cocktails interacting with everybody it
really is a one-of-a-kind las vegas
tradition that happens here only at red
rocket scene well we love a las vegas
tradition in las vegas now and i know
there is a big dj booth so tell us about
the music aspect of this place yep we
have a dj going we open at five o'clock
on fridays and saturdays we're gonna go
until about one a.m and then sunday's
about midnight so it's a party yeah yeah
come after nine o'clock and you're gonna
have a great time i love that now i have
been here off the clock you know as a
guest and i had so much fun and the
atmosphere is great you know you have
little bites of food you have the
cocktail menu so we're going to
talk to taylor in depth about the
cocktails but what's on the menu
um so our cocktails are some of our
favorites so naughty until proven
innocent is probably my favorite
cocktail yup and taylor i think we'll
throw that cocktail off
and then we have a few other interactive
cocktails and then there's also a secret
menu attached to it but taylor will
explain some of the secret menu and then
if you go on our website you'll be able
to pick up on some of these tidbits oh
wow okay so how can you make a
reservation what do people need to do
yep so go to our website red
redrockcasinoresort.com go to merry
crimson you can book through there or
through our concierge team
702-797-7823 and they'll be able to book
your table here at merry crimson and you
did mention that you don't need a
reservation but it's recommended
definitely recommended to give that that
true red rock experience we're known for
okay make sure you just picture ready
okay because there's so many pictures
places in here it's beautiful i love the
elegant vibe this year yep i'm excited
to come back off the clock yeah please
do please rocky thank you so much to you
and the viewers for always coming up
thank you joe all right well so coming
up later in the show we're going to talk
to this lady over here doing working her
magic behind the bar and talk all things
cocktails here great prison i'll put it
back to you
i love it i love that new feel like an
elegant feel to it like a magical winter
wonderland i can't wait to see some of
those cocktails they look fun and just
the names alone just order them it's a
lot of fun play all day sign me up for
that one